the crowd went out of Cheers hearing
that former police officer Derek shavon
is now facing second-degree murder
charges in the death of George Floyd the
three other officers involved employed
x' arrests are also now charged with
aiding and abetting I strongly believe
that these developments are in the
interest of justice for mr. Floyd his
family our community and our state the
news came just hours after Floyd's son
arrived at the spot where his 46 year
old father died and knelt in prayer I
appreciate everyone joining some support
and love I thank y'all for that the
Minneapolis Police Department is now
under investigation for discriminatory
practices but activists say that does
not give them solace an arrest is not a
conviction and we want justice you know
we don't want posture justice we will
hold justice former President Obama held
a virtual Town Hall late Wednesday
urging the nation's mayor's to review
police use of force policies we both
have to highlight a problem and make
people in power uncomfortable but we
also have to translate that into
practical solutions and laws that can be
implemented demonstrators have kept up
calls for justice for George Floyd
across the u.s. despite tense clashes
with police and incidents of looting the
message is now in here in Minnesota for
the last five days come back to the
issue at hand which is the systemic
issues and the systemic racism Floyd's
family and friends will gather in
Minneapolis Thursday for the first
memorial service in his honor